Vladimir I saw you coming here you look
very satisfied with this result but more
importantly I think with this game it
was such a precise game I have to say
tell us a bit about how you experienced
it how you lived it
yeah it was very complicated I have to
say and my preparation uh finished
somewhere around
uh okay E4 I knew that there is there
are such movie for but somehow I did not
concentrate much on this just feeling
that it should be good for black instead
of Knight AC Queen A5 also like also the
way to play but then five here
yeah I played D5 because I mean many
moves are possible here I believe that
logic I mean it's very logical and the
correct way I believe I have to because
now I mean black is already like
lagging behind in development right too
much and it's time I saw that just to
sacrifice something to like get free
uh but I'm not sure I mean it's only one
of possible ways to play D5 and I really
liked it at least from a practical
perspective because yeah technical
definitely it's correct I believe
they're so difficult right and he has a
lot of decisions to make also yeah sure
yeah sure we actually we both we we have
many possibilities like on each move and
here United States everything is is no
yeah Community I was surprised of course
to see because I believe it's just bad
move uh instead of course long castles
Maine I believe long castles King F7 I
wanted to play and now King B2 yes I was
scared okay E5 he will sacrifice now I
don't know I can't lose I'm crazy five
yes I'm crazy I believe that somewhere
around equal should build these
positions right
but this is of course the way to play
maybe there are some other but here I
mean A5 is the most Resolute way
probably to play for black but even if I
don't play five black is fine perhaps
this is something that he missed because
it is a peace sacrifice at this point
you kind of commit yeah yeah guys but I
believe it's easy to sacrifice here
because all black pieces are ready for
here there is our K5 so I was just
wondering a little bit about rookette
but Rook A5 actually my problem also
after 2K6 is that after Knight takes C8
uh E5 white will always plays D4 I
believe just take some Knights that's
right yeah and even if my Rook is on A5
or on A6 same and okay he he does not
risk much here it's probably just yeah
no I mean right now he's pressing
probably even personally yeah maybe so
at this I just I just immediately like
[Music]
yeah maybe D4 yeah because okay I mean
it's not the only way definitely to play
for white here
um
okay Knight B7 here Knight B7 his
position is pretty much losing at this
point already yes yes yes
so somehow I calculated till C4 and it
looks like it's very somehow set
position for a ride at least I am not
sure if I mean I I was playing right
here but uh still it's very unpleasant
therefore for example after E5 Bishop E3
I believe man still yeah to give up this
bishop Bishop takes D4 I believe and
takes on B4 something like this look
this before before Rook takes a 200
Short castles maybe this way just
playing with two Rooks maybe maybe it's
time already to do such such things yeah
uh because uh like after Bishop C1
somehow
it becomes quickly completely lost
yeah and also also you know instead of
group B2 this move I don't like instead
of Rook B2 just go back maybe maybe just
castles again just maybe maybe it's
better I don't know but still A5 seems
to be yeah yeah it seems to be a very
unpleasant you know probably C4 actually
Max missed this C4 because C4 comes on
all pieces like coming and
difficult to to to to to defend this
already you must have been quite happy
when you saw the early on imbalances in
this game because 50 surely you're still
quite far away from the top position
which I'm sure you want to to get to
tell us a bit about that moment when you
first started and he first saw this
opening phase playing in your favor
um okay I did not think about that I
mean if had I thought about yesterday uh
the day before yesterday I would have
played completely different stuff yeah
at least I could repeat moves and make a
draw because I understood that black is
not better I mean black black has very
beautiful position but he's definitely
not better because okay Whitehead has no
weaknesses with uh with Alex yes and
only that I wanted to to continue yeah I
did not want to make this boring draw
night between Knight C4 like this and on
the other hand somehow I did not see
concrete wage to improve my position and
this was the problem so I understood of
course that this H5 H4 Pawn sacrifice
very dubious but still I I felt that
okay I have to do something and to play
so yeah I did not uh think much I just
wanted I would to have interesting game
just to to play interesting chess
and the game was interesting itself but
Max was that at some point especially
Queen D3 actually it was of course I
believe somehow with Queen D3 He
immediately like agrees that white is
not better and he tries to like equalize
and play this but the position is is
different I mean these two moves before
and queen D3 doesn't come with together
they don't combine very well together
Vladimir your fighting Spirit has
definitely been rewarded today
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you yes
questions